Bayonetta Bayonetta 2 Bayonetta 2 is the
sequel to the successful but not very
well known Bayonetta that came out on
ps3 this one however is on the Wii U one
of the most underrated systems ever and
you should probably buy it now I just
want to let you guys know there is going
to be kind of an influx of game reviews
coming your way because I am starting to
take reviewing games more seriously and
I would like to do it more regularly on
my channel also there's not much coming
out in the next few weeks in regards to
movies there's the hunger games so I
have a lot of games to talk to you guys
about including Assassin's Creed unity
and Super Smash for the Wii U and
Bayonetta 2 so look forward to that guys
as you guys know I'm a fan of movies I'm
a fan of anime and I'm a fan of games
and that's why within the first five
minutes Bayonetta 2 just felt right so
Bayonetta can summon anything she wants
she has ridiculously awesome powers
she's absurdly sexy independent strong
and she can kick a lot of ass and she is
really fun to play as in one of the best
action games of the year and in all
honesty one of the most addictive games
I've ever played I couldn't set this
controller down I swear to you I was
playing Bayonetta 2 far too long this is
a very horrendously addictive game that
kept me sitting down for hours on end
when I really should have gotten some
sleep it was like the old days I
remember when I was a kid staying up
late playing games like Silent Hill or
starfox 64 and not sleeping because I
was so into the game and I would go to
school tired if this game came out when
I was like 14 I would be spending
sleepless days in school all day the
basic plot of the game is that you are
accompanying a boy that she
affectionately refers to as little one
he's got some skills of his own and they
are trying to get someplace and it's a
strange mythological world filled with
insane creatures that pop out of the
ground almost every two seconds and you
are a badass and you're really hot
that's Bayonetta 2 it sounds very simple
but the game is surprising in a lot of
ways specifically I found it genuinely
funny the game has a lot of attempts at
humor and a lot of winks at the audience
not just with the fan service of
Bayonetta's out
fit but with certain characters and
there's a lot of humor in this game
think about it some of the best action
movies are filled with humor some of the
best action games are just fun to play
but there isn't that humor that's
keeping it kind of grounded Bayonetta 2
is actually a very funny game if we're
going to sake she has guns on her heels
you can do a breakdance move where you
spin around shooting everything around
and then you do like a pose and wink at
the camera it's incredible I mean I felt
like I was in Zoolander ok they're
breakdance fighting there's my peg
another great thing about this game that
kind of reminded me of Super Mario
Galaxy is that it plays with gravity a
lot it'll flip things and you have to
jump to an area then all of a sudden you
flip to the other side of it stuff like
that and it's all seamless the
transition is perfect the locations in
the background are beautifully rendered
and there's very little loading time as
well in fact even when it is loading
they give you the option to practice
your combos as Bayonetta which makes it
even faster and out of all the Wii U
games I've played so far this is by far
the best-looking with the best graphics
in fact up until now I've kind of felt
that ps3 and Wii U had comparable
graphics but this in my opinion shoots
above ps3 s capabilities and really
shows that the Wii U has a lot of hidden
talent in there that they haven't even
accessed yet as soon as you get past the
fairly long opening cutscene this is
almost a non-stop action game in every
room you walk into there's like a new
boss battle there'll be boss battles
like every minute it's insane and it's
extremely fun there isn't a game that
I've played recently that is this fast
paced with no rendering issues with no
loading problems and with no framerate
drop also the battle cutscenes in the
game are really great and better
directed than a lot of action scenes and
movies in the theater nowadays this game
has the best graphics on the Wii U that
I have seen has some of the most
satisfying action of the year as a very
likable and funny lead character great
boss battles beautifully rendered
locales an awesome combat system and if
you aren't convinced that you need to
buy this game and a Wii U the game even
comes with a ported version of the first
Bayonetta if you haven't played it yet
what's your excuse man
this game along with Donkey Kong Country
tropical freeze Super Mario 3d World
Mario Kart 8 Pikmin 3 what's your excuse
for not owning a Wii U at this point
because they are really impressing me
and I really think it's a very
underrated system and you guys should
pick it up because they're really
starting to pump out awesome games Super
Smash is coming out next week I'm gonna
give ban net a two and nine point five
out of ten the only reason that I'm not
giving it a 10 is because there are
times where the story just isn't that
interesting and a little convoluted but
it's such a random complaint in a game
filled with so much ridiculous
awesomeness so guys since I am talking
about something that I feel is
underrated in the Wii U system I thought
it might be cool if I recommended a game
that I also think is underrated that is
older and that game is called Shenmue
for the Sega Dreamcast if you guys have
a dreamcast dusted off see if you can
find a copy of Shenmue it's a game that
has a huge cult following even still
Shenmue dojo com still has a ton of
posts in the forum from people who
really want to continue the story and
see how it ends because Shenmue 2 came
out for the Xbox in America Dreamcast
over in Japan and the plan Shenmue 3
never really happened so the story is
kind of up in the air but it is a really
cool game and I strongly suggest you
guys checking this out at some point
guys thank you so much as always for
watching I'll have more game reviews
coming soon including Assassin's Creed
unity and Super Smash Brothers for the
Wii you look forward to that guys thank
you so much as always for watching and
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]
Oh